tandis que vous étiez bien amusé sur
l'application facebook live
ah ça vous dit quelque chose là cette
gold microsoft a sorti un album qui
s'appelle murphy et murphy son travail
c'est quoi ces deux faits choix p as ta
place les choses en gros il faut
toujours commencer par what if qui veut
dire je le sais et si ça doit vouloir
dire ici bons achats et qu'est-ce qui se
passerait si on était pas loin par
exemple oualich nicolas sarkozy was the
girl qu'est ce qui se passait si nicolas
sarkozy était une fille et là il nous
envoie une photo de nicolas sarkozy au
mof
est-ce que c'est pas exceptionnel si
c'est fantastique et si squeeze tu es
une fille va pas trouver sonné une meuf
qui se parent masque de beauté
tranquillement il est doué il est doué
paru sur la même photo de filles quand
tu mets le mot fille il a qu'une photo
en stock à temps c'est vrai en plus il
va pas mettre en boule sur une même
planche bon je pense quand tu mets was
the girl mais forcément cette meuf là
c'est n'importe quoi et c'est tellement
scandaleux oualich françois hollande
wazen elephant man selon unité dans
l'effort
comment ces gens font mec c'est
tellement bien et si iron man était
capitaine américain peut michael steve a
fait quoi il a pris une affiche où il ya
une moitié visage de chacun et la juste
1000 à la gueule de tony stark trouve
dans le christ est scandaleux a time on
a fait nos troubles a dit ce qu'ils ont
fait mais non et regardez où ils nous
avaient été les stars qui me la met sur
youtube qu'est ce que c'est et si
jennifer lawrence est ténue ah non
pardon et cyprien était un combattant au
nom un style hors norme double lunettes
on combat plus que quiconque ait ouali
enjoy phoenix oiseaux phoenix tu as fuck
c'est improbable n'a pas fait ta routine
temps et si tu le quittes et booster le
masters c'est la grosse armure d'iron
man d'accord on part sur une photo vous
avez quatre secondes pour trouver la
tête du 1e c'est parti
oui depuis des bulles qui est en fait la
rotule deux buteurs et oui je viens de
vous spoiler d'avengers deux essais
squeeze été musclé c'est là qu'on va
tester leurs capacités murphy pour mais
pourquoi tu trouves que cette [ __ ] une
autre arène mais arrête avec ce mec il
est obstiné à garder ce visage il faut
arrêter tout de suite attendant si je
marchais mais il est un autre visage
avant la le voilà le squeeze content
d'avoir enfin trouvé ses muscles [ __ ]
et si chewbacca était un chien peut
arriver à les bâtards immo brain
qu'est ce qui se passait si mac les
morts étaient une clément juste y ont
posé des questions elle est le fatah est
compris la claque les morts les paie moi
je parle de la mine mais franchement
avec le barça doit bien être personnel
mer et c'est beyoncé qui tant fait jaser
mon coeur ah oui bon gillett bouge
tellement grosse qu'ils ont même pas
réussi lundi à un détecteur moga et
c'est fantastique j'ai adoré ça devrait
se passer si françois hollande était
président une nouvelle fois ça pas du
tout mais refile à la mère fume il ya
trop de surchauffe et je crois que les
trois affaires de faith web de merde et
en veut plus et si obama était françois
hollande oui c'est ça mon gars le tag
est là
piscine normative nous était un enfant
ah oui oui c'est magnifique une autre
une autre
oh oui attend il arrive à tourner
l'image comme s'ils étaient de profil
[ __ ] c'est ou encore mais attendez ça
c'est une vraie photo normal que j'étais
petit excellent suivre et si thibault in
shape était maigre et afoc et afoc type
a dit était une femme arrêtés mérite
mais c'est incroyable à tort watsa pour
me refuser maigre ça marche
[ __ ] et si legolas était en fait un
jedi
oui oui je l' ai toujours su le vrai
visage de l'udc
et si yoda avait des cheveux qu'est ce
que ça fait au we would apprends moi
c'est une période à ma propre jeu vous
dira voilà ça c'est mon maître sas à
celui qui m'a transmis la force
et si naoto a vu un enfant et s'éduquer
oui c'est bizarre non
jeter à la poubelle on n'en veut pas aux
mots dieu et si michael jackson était en
vie à l'accord ok donc la peau blanche
suffisait plus ils voulaient carrément
devenir une femme manon summer murphy tu
arrêtes tout de suite oh [ __ ] murphy
va mettre fin au débat éternel et si un
pas en chocolat est en fait une
chocolatine mon dieu roi the va je
déteste merci et si nos masques a été
d'un bon jeu mais qu'est ce que tu
racontes murphy tu délires et 6 1 3
daniel était chaud comme ça plus aucun
problème avec tes cheveux antoine daniel
et si maître gims était blanc comme ans
a dû le guet et si moi j'étais noir
pourquoi tu es si près en moi j'ai pas
le droit d'accéder à la couleur de peau
noire c'est ça qu'est ce qui se passait
c'est kim kardashian était un papier
un vrai papillon non mais [ __ ] de
merde
ah voilà voilà ce que c'est de la merde
ici obama était français le cliché du
béret rouge et de la tour eiffel en plus
les mains la grosse tête avait un truc à
faire mais il ya un truc
et si hollande était américain alors là
tu vois ma fille je sortais pas mémé tu
as réussi à faire plus fort dans le
cliché club photo d'avant et si les
humains étaient des animaux c'est tout
ce que tu trouves avère [ __ ] et si
will smith était harley quinn
oh oui c'est bon ça et si ce quiz est
éteinte à caution voulu être un tacot ce
mondial déjà j'ai l'eau d'heure quand je
transpirais ensuite en mon dieu oh mon
dieu mon rêve
enfin bon ben je sais pas cette vidéo
sur project murphy chose la plus
inusitée paix mais elle doit comme
d'habitude pas s'y perdre en fait parce
qu'on sait jamais quelle photo il va
utiliser et qu'elle mixe pourri ça va
donner pour sauter des procédures merci
d'avoir regardé portez vous bien le chat
au monde
pis